this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer what you just
witnessed was the Shazam app recognizing
a song in a noisy environment and
proceeding to find a match for it among
the millions of songs in its servers
database for most this probably seems
like a trivial task our brains can
identify songs incredibly quickly from a
young age but the pathways in your brain
that allow you to identify a song
quickly are incredibly complex often
times you simply need to hear just a few
chords to know exactly what song is
about to play that jolt of excitement
when you can hear a DJ fading in the
baseline of your favorite song a simple
combination of tones in a specific order
allow you to identify a song from the
thousands of other songs you have heard
in your life
in an instant by coding a computer to do
the same thing is an incredible
challenge a computer does not have an
intuitive understanding of music a
computer can only compare songs to other
songs in its database looking for a
match by comparison it is a problem akin
to finding a needle in a haystack where
you can only find the needles by looking
at a picture of a needle and comparing
it to each individual straw comparing
its length and color until you finally
find the needle to create a software
capable of doing this quickly poses a
very interesting coding challenge and
the solution the engineers at Shazam
came up with gives us some interesting
insight into how our brains work a study
by the Manchester Museum of Science and
Industry tested 12,000 people's ability
to recognize a song they created an
interactive game to search for the most
recognizable songs where they would play
the hook of 1000 best-selling songs and
record the time required to identify
them can you identify this song which is
2.3 seconds of the horse that was the
Spice Girls song wannabe which ranks
highest with the recognition time
averaging just 2.3 seconds and that's
including the reaction time required to
hit the button our brains are hard-wired
for this kind of pattern recognition in
a world were recognising the sound of an
approaching threat mental life or death
we have evolved incredibly efficient
ways of category
and assessing historical data like this
our brain does not take the sound and
compare it to every sound we've ever
heard like a computer the specific
combination of courts in progression
simply activates specific neurons that
unlock that historical data what if the
chords were played by a different
instrument would we recognize the song
as quickly those same two point three
seconds played on guitar sounds like
this the notes are exactly the same but
they don't sound exactly the same we
even know intuitively what instrument is
playing why is that this is called a
timbre of the note and different
instruments have different timbres
pianos and guitars are examples of
harmonic instruments and when they
produce a note they aren't just
producing a pure note of a single
frequency each note is a combination of
multiple frequencies all related to the
bass note the fundamental frequency
these are called overtones and there are
simply multiples of the bass frequency
each instrument has a unique combination
and evolution of these overtones that
give that unique sound again it's quite
easy for our brains to distinguish
between a piano and a guitar but we need
a way to quantify these characteristics
for a computer to recognize and this is
where the spectrogram comes in a
spectrogram is a visual representation
of sound it's a 3d graph with time on
the x-axis and frequency on the y-axis
and the amplitude of the frequency or in
other words the loudness on the z-axis
which is often represented by a color
this 3d graph is something a computer
can absolutely recognize and store as
data but there is a huge amount of data
within a spectrogram like this and the
more data there is the more computation
time is required to find a match so the
first step in reducing computation time
is reducing the data required to
classify a song Shazam uses something
called a fingerprint where they
transform these spectrograms into
something that looks like a star map
here each star represents the strongest
frequencies at particular times doing
this we've not only reduced our graph
from three dimensions down to two but
I've drastically reduced the amount of
data points on the graph this is the
first vital part of Shazam's technology
every single song and Shazam's database
is stored in a fingerprint like this
when you open your phone and hit that
Shazam button the app accesses your
microphone and begins to create its own
fingerprint of the sound waves it
receives this ingenious method also
helps the Shazam up to filter out noise
because it only creates data points for
standout frequencies once the app has
created a fingerprint of your audio it
then sends it to the Shazam servers
where the recognition part of the
process begins this is where things get
difficult let's look at a simplified
song fingerprint and a recorded
fingerprint to see why the recorded
fingerprint is only a short recording of
the song in our example we have just
three possible frequencies and each
recorded fingerprint will have just
three time points if we want to check
the first three time points in the song
for a match we first check the three
frequencies then we move on to the next
time point and check the three possible
frequencies again and do the same for
the final time point if we find a match
that is nine operations required to find
a match but obviously that isn't likely
we then need to do those nine operations
for every time point in the song or
perhaps every point in Shazam's massive
music archive this obviously is going to
take a lot of computation time this is
not houses arm looks for a match first
Shazam categorizes fingerprints in a
clever way we don't search to see if a
note exists in a song we search to see
if several notes exists separated by a
particular time just as our brain does
this becomes our searchable address for
a hash table hashes and hash functions
are an incredibly useful technique that
appear everywhere in computer science
hash functions can be found in search
algorithms used by Google to make sure
files are downloaded correctly and are
the backbone of crypto currencies like
Bitcoin a hash function takes a varying
length of input and produces a fixed
length output called a hash in practice
the input can be anything from a short
piece of text like a password to a long
data stream like an entire movie
consider a library of books we want to
store each book on a shelf so that we
can find it later and we know we'll have
the title of the book when we're
searching for it we can use a hash
function to decide which shelf to put a
book on using the title of the book as
the input and producing a shelf number
as an
the first goal of a hash function is to
produce outputs that are uniformly
distributed in our library we want the
books to be spread evenly across the
shelves so no shelf in particular will
end up full of books leaving others
almost empty
the second goal of the hash function is
that it should reduce collisions a
collision is when two different inputs
produce the same output hash in our case
a collision results in two or more books
on the same shelf if our library only
has two shelves collisions will be
really common no matter what hash
function you use if our library had a
billion shells a good hash function will
mean collisions will be rare another
goal of hash function is that it should
be quick to calculate if our library has
millions of books we don't want to take
too long figuring out which shelf each
one needs to be on a simple hash
function might be to take the title of a
book and group them on shelves
alphabetically this would be really
quick to calculate but it would result
in a lot of collisions with many books
on the same shelf and wouldn't be well
distributed think about how many books
begin with the word the' compared to how
many books start with the letters ed an
alternative might be to take the
position of each letter in the alphabet
and sum up the letters in the book title
we could then divide that number by the
number of shelves we have and take the
remainder as the shelf number to store
the book on this would still be fairly
fast to calculate and would prevent all
the books with titles starting with the
word the' being stored on the same shelf
now imagine instead of book titles our
hash function takes data from our to
frequencies separated by a particular
time as an input T and produces a number
between 1 and say 1 billion first we go
through our database of songs and
calculate the hash number for each
Anchor Point pairs songs will contain
multiple anchor points which will allow
us to categorize short snippets of songs
by the frequency of the anchor point the
frequency of the following point and the
time between them and just like the
library we store each anchor point in
order by the hash these addresses are
also categorized with song IDs and
timestamps within the song in a
secondary hash table allowing us to
search for matching songs this makes it
much faster to locate our matches and to
find our song we
multiple matching anchor points this
ingenious method of song recognition
allowed Shazam to be sold for 400
million dollars to Apple and help you
figure out just what that catchy song is
this is a very simplified view of how
the programming of Shazam works but I've
linked my research materials below if
you'd like to read more into the process
or if you'd like to begin learning more
about programming and build a solid
foundation of understanding then you
could take this course on computer
science fundamentals on brilliant which
we'll start with an intro to algorithms
and gradually build you to more complex
ideas like data types and structures by
the end of this course you will have
discovered algorithms that can be used
to extract answers from data and when
you are finished you can take this
follow up course in computer science
algorithms this is just one of many
courses on brilliant with more courses
due to be really soon on things like
automotive engineering and Python coding
if I have inspired you and you want to
educate yourself then go to brilliant
org ford slash real engineering and sign
up for free and the first 73 people that
go to that link will get 20% off their
annual premium subscription as always
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below
you